This is mr. Harold rootsy who worked as
a stone mason at the quarry at maria for
dorman long back in the days of the
building of the bridge. Do you member
how you got the job. Do you mr.
Ity. Yes well i just came out of me. Time
in sydney and there's nothing doing up
here. And the mayor mascot was the
manager of the firm that i work for
and i was through him and the
friends of is that a dime
a doorman and long we were sent down to see
them and that's where we first started
off and got down there to maria. Do you
remember when you got there and how you
first started you member what it was
like all the work was very heavy because
a big block. We had to to get but then we
come. Alright. We got used to it. Did
you work in the quarry or in the stone
dressing sheds in the stone dressing shed
on the stone dressing. Did you split the
blocks down first. Or did it split for you
know they could they were carried first
in that's into the rough and we made them
out of the rough each block was made at
the rough sea and how did you go about
that. Well we had pneumatic tools and that
and chisels and just you get a rough
block and you have to take it out
a square per square up at four pegs and
then when you got the face of it. Excuse me
. There were four pegs pegs like you put
the corners of the stone when you get the
three ice the three lowest points
of the stone of the stone and put
a peg in the lowest part the next highest
point the next one and the highest point
. Take the poor pigs across and then
you cite them and that's how you get
a square when you strike with
a straight edge cross each in. And then
when you start to cut and with the
pneumatic tools do you put a dry what
i call a draft around that's like
a flat level right around and then you get
when you get the rough out of it get the
gig to be a better or
a joint you're putting on. And then when
that's on that's when you take your
measurements and that's when
you start anything put on
a bevel was the job different from
other jobs particularly no you know
what i was used to where did you serve
it. And what we used to i was at my
modelling and sons at the where the airport
is now used to be on the airport now
it's not the you know no more. It's where
it was and that was my first job there
was on the government savings bank which
is the commerce department now time work
around there and we did that come
from italy already ran it and
you cut it up here. It was also on and use
different sort of process to what it was
down there but all roughed out and then
finished off and then the polished.
Different bridge the bridge. Job was all
split and cut wasn't rustic there was no
there was no cutting with sources no no
no. And all by hand out of the rough you
got the rough block not us or on new down
from the rough. And the different sizes
of stones that was all worked out beforehand
exactly what size you would need that
you'd get a plan you get
a sketch of the job in the size of
it and then you went on bevels like
a different people's fourteen 114 to an age
when you got to bevel goes up the sides
. And that's if you go from the big in the
bottom the smaller the top. That's an
incredible job but it was all that will
be accurate and it'll be you know where
they fit in. You can see that now that
i fit in. That'll be right because you
couldn't. Mess one up and shot it away
when you got on the job they're not like
shot a bit of brick or a bit of timber
a way. You know the square sides
were they moved off by it. Also with
a hand when we do it as i
say when we took them out
a square with the pegs we'd
put out what they call
a servicing machine on as like we call
a four point and that would be bought by
compressed air and it would jump up and
down and that knocked the stone down to
level. And then to be awed and by no matter
how much and then smaller children tools
that we used to have the train. What about
the rock face how was that and the others
rough side. That was just pitched often
left. Would have been pitched off. Well
when you got to the flat. They just took it
out a square not your
face on. But if you had
a rock face which is all it is now you
just pitched it down and left it with
a pitch until and knocked it off and just
left it as it is. A pitching tool was
that pneumatic or was it hand or hand drill
hand we used to have. Did you do any
further and which work. Sometimes we might
take a bit. It was a bit heavy we'd put
a couple of plugs and feathers you
know and knock it out on a bed to
a joint sonny on bed and joint like it was
a bit heavy stuff. To member the working
conditions down there in the shop. Yes i
was quite happy with them. What was
it like was it windy. Oh no i can't i
couldn't complain the time i was there.
I see wearing masks as well. Compulsory
that was only one servicing
machines only doing what they call
a four point but very rarely we did i use
them. Do you remember any injuries down
. They want to cup our they were before
my time those two there they were for my
time the two that were killed but the one
that happened to you in the film is. Tell
us about that. Oh well i just punching
a big british big not knocked off
a block and you know what they call
a ball to want what i'm like
it's about the hammer with
a seven pound hammer or ten and not aimed
at the side because it came off and up
onto me. Toe and let me try one. And what
happened then i had about six weeks off
work and i walked from the
quarry to cameroon about two and
a half miles. No transport then they wouldn't
give you transport. I never asked for
it. I do stupid. I think i got
to got everywhere artery. You
walked all the way and then you know all
the way. And then after that you were at
work is complete. I don't really know
of about that. Now whether we've got
compensation or not i
suppose we would have got
a bright forgotten all about that. Now i
don't think any other week with i got to
not work. What do you did you work there
and what we won it was just there in
1931 towards the latter the blocks down
the last of the world. It was time well
workers come came in 1926. I must have got
it but i said do you mean where you live
when you worked in so i lived in places
to call the clubhouse hotels an old hotel
run by mrs.
Keeper and i was in queen street maria.
And how did you get to work where we used
to have cast quarters of
a morning. Take it out and in the
afternoon come out and bring us back and
do you remember the town
of maria and there's
a yes. Not about it or town. But the middle
of it. So tell us about that. I don't
think i would come on is
a long time ago. Now you know i
forgot all about that now was
a good really good happy town you know get
a good time there. Well well
that's all i can tell you
a couple of girls there. Used to go in
the pub there as well. They have dances
there. You know you tap dance at the
quarry. I mean one time i suppose
a fiddle little bit then and with
them to dance placements to come out
there and he has to be there to make
home brewing up there is to make
a bit of
a still out there. I believe i don't know
where it was i had an idea where it was
and i used to come out and i got wind of
an energy to dance with them and only come
out one night you write about
a month after you got him with them. You
remember the quarry workers there where
did they come from and they were scotch
there was no matter what happened. Scotland
. Nearly all the scotch
a few italians and they mostly scotch
they were they were the families where
there's got the families blacksmiths and
all embassy and they were quarryman can
you describe granite turn. Yet it was
a little place out there.
That was just they were all
weatherboard places you know makeshift
places and they're really comfortable they
really really good. Do you make some friends
amongst the scots with a woman. I had
a couple of girlfriends there. Were good
little girls. And you got what do you
remember of the italians. One or two i
didn't i didn't expect them they were like
get a bit of
a fine work on there and his name.
You know andrew someone. They
were all right. Scotch they were the people
next with some sort of people tell me
that the italians were pretty well all
single and it was the scots that brought the
family there they were single most of the
i don't know about like remember back
about four or five italians to remember
any union activity there. Yes. We
. The chap there won't mention
his name was written. And
he is the character of a nice
bloke. And he's working on
a job there one day and this is a bit
slow. So they have to get a bit of
a move on and that's what happened what
they said to him but now. I don't know
where that is right but in the i work in
just opposite him. And they came along
with the crane and took the
job they're working on
a way the way calls are not in the work
and then and cause that caused the strike
and where they stop work
meeting and you know there's
a big bloke the name terry love. Big
wild like we vote for us. He was
a stickler even where this meeting any
civil union rights wouldn't come down put.
So he said take up
a collection send me up to sydney he says
now bring them down so he said. And if i
don't come back. Send me
a bunch of flowers there now that was settled
after that he did come to sydney that
was settled and got the job got
his job back again. But he's
a really good bloke. Yeah that was one bit
of union activity. Do you remember the
working conditions around the place you
have somewhere to have your lunch and
somewhere to have boiler tea and things
like that. You know is happening to the
bank as well we used to work on our job.
You know no there was there were i don't
know there's
a canteen they won't ever used to take me
lunch out. I don't really need canteen
a part they would have been
on the because it was that
a big hole i suppose. Right because i did
on the job the people who live there.
They want to canteen actually. But i don't
remember of one being there. Can you
describe granite town as you member it was
no what the town itself was no different
than any other place only
it was a nice little
a nice position on the side the river the
murray river and they built the houses
place the around the area like
oh that's about all i can
tell you about that there
was a hall was there in
a school and salty and so all their school
i think they used to go. I don't know
whether they used to go to maru school years
just down little school down the year
they did happen. You know like
a little bridge they go under
a bridge i think it was which you get your
supplies from then. Well i used to come
to from sydney i suppose you know days
by boat and but used to run up there and
really one time many lorries going to taze
know they mostly on the ships used to
come to maria. And do you
remember you could you pay. No
i think we used to have to queue up yet.
Care at the office for it. You had your
own office. The little office at
the place i showed you there. As
a matter of fact there's a there's
a lady who works in the office is still
around. I wouldn't know what to name. I
think it's ross i'm not not absolutely
certain you. You'll probably meet her at the
reunion. She will be out of me. Well i
don't know i haven't met her yet i have an
area. I just got
a list. Oh yes on our manager gilmore he
used to live on the other side the river
used to come to us by launch every morning
and back in the pinoy time
even though there really
a good crowd of people
i really i really had
a wonderful time while i was down there. I
enjoyed it. What about the other manager
the stern dressing managers. I can't bring
them back they were all late and felt
a lot of them there to give
you a job saying you got
a job for about four or five days you
might be complete for two weeks on
a one job. So it all depends. That's
why you're trying to come and give me
a sketch of the job you had to do and then
it wouldn't turn out and if you do what
you want the next job. Will
you mean a job one block or
a number of blocks take you. How long it
might be you might be able to turn them
off for a week
a couple of weeks as forty much work within
them. There's 40000 blocks i understand
on that side but if you mean i'm a card on
a few. It was amazing to me how do you
remember how many of you were there were
working in the stands. Just trying to think
last night in the dressing part of it.
I'd say they will. I don't know what i'd
be wrong side of the bout might be about
thirty or forty masons and i
wouldn't be quite sure now but quite
a few where were the rest
of them because i got
a figure of all there as quarryman and all
that they were in the quarry part of it
last. Every day and that seemed to when i'm
going to blast and you know get away up
down
a flight of the sheds where you worked and
pieces of the language from the block
when they blasted the court it was only
just back of the sheds wasn't it. Yeah i'm
trying to shed. Do you remember how
many court i mean there were no i
just taken from guesswork
there may have been about
a dozen and i'd say i don't think i'd be
much more you see i heard that there were
200 or 250 people working at the quarry and
how did they manage to get there. Well
i don't know whether they'd be that
many there may have been but i don't
think they're going to be that many of
them may have been i don't know but their
families and all their might have been
a lot of other jobs they were doing
around i didn't know. Oh well it was
a quarryman and then there was the stone
dressing blokes and whatever who else was
there. Well. Well the little
office i think that about half
a dozen people in there and then the
draftsman there and then they did that you
know with the right of the plane not to
give us get the size of the blocks out of
out there to be done. And they give us
a little sketch on paper and we had better
work from that including that i suppose
it would have been like looking after
machinery part of it at their own power there
. I suppose there could be but i think in
a wrong way back. There.